[Music]
I'm Korando here with Joe Hill and
you're about to have your own corner of
the DC comic universe and I could not be
more excited how did this all start
how's it coming to fruition what's the
story well first of all I just want to
say it's great to be on Collider to be
talking to you and stuff and you know
Todd McFarlane was sitting in this exact
seat just a moment ago I'm sitting here
in Todd McFarlane's butt sweat and I
have to say I'm feeling inspired and a
little move a lot of cross hatching a
lot of big ideas I'm stoked the so yeah
I'm doing a line of horror comic books
for for DC I'm doing a it's it's a comic
book in print called Hill House I'm
writing a couple of them and then we've
got some a story tellers to write a few
more I'm very excited for you know I
mean this is a project I've been talking
about with Mark Doyle who was an editor
at DC since 2017 and basically I pitched
him on Blum House for comics you know I
mean people ask me like what's the
Golden Age of horror and the answer is
we're living it right now it's happening
right this instant and and you know
there's been it used to be a film like
The Exorcist came maybe every five years
you know a film that was like felt like
a landmark now we get him every six
months pictures like get out hereditary
it follows I mean real you know towering
fright flicks that have sort of elevated
the Jean or and brought it to a new
level we've seen the same thing you know
on the streaming channels and TV shows
like stranger things you know which kind
of broke the mold and and expanded our
whole sense of what's possible in horror
and I want I want comics to get in on
the action so that's what we're gonna
try to do I don't think it's ever been a
better time to be either a comic fan or
a horror fan and it's been alarming that
horror comics don't get the attention I
think they're about to yeah well you
know the thing is people have to
remember that this business was built on
great horror comics like up until about
1953 1954 the biggest sellers in comics
were all horror comic books and then for
those who know their comic book history
they
was a correctional committee looking
into juvenile delinquency and that
committee essentially said horror comics
are twisting kids minds and perverting
their souls they were right yeah but but
don't tell them that
and so actually comics not squeaky clean
for about forty years and and then
things started to swing in the other
direction with the British Invasion in
the 1990s and this influx of great
writers like Neil Gaiman and Alan Moore
and you know and and they changed they
brought horror back they brought you
know and most of more writing for DC and
so I definitely feel like I'm in good
hands over there that I'm with the
people who made horror awesome and
comics again yet named war was the rebel
which is how squeaky-clean things were
an exact totally imperious Rex was like
a swear right but now we're living in a
time where like you mentioned stranger
things but also even even here in San
Diego we had scare Diego where it
chapter two had its first footage shown
because the culture is ready for that
kind of like exposure I mean I thought I
thought that it the first chapter one
was one of the scariest films ever made
completely then and I think it's chapter
two looks like it might potentially blow
it out of the water i I was there and
the phone I just I never thought we'd
see that on screen much less to this
scale and they did it I'm so excited I'm
so excited and you know so what's so so
let's take a second to talk about why it
is great because I think it applies to
the horror genre as a whole you know and
Ian and Barbara muschietti who made it
they they clearly loved their characters
and the actors they take care of those
actors and they you know they have
tremendous effects and you can feel we
fall in love with those characters
because they're in love with them and
and you know great horror is not about
sadism it's not about throwing entrails
at the camera it's about taking some
characters that we can fall in love with
and then putting them through the
Thresher you know and and forcing them
to face the worst and and so really
great horror is about compassion
it's about empathy and I think you know
with movies like it we see that full
force you know stranger things is the
same way
this has nothing to do with my comic
it's based on the Shirley Jackson novel
but the haunting Hill House which was
created by Mike Flanagan same thing very
very frightening but the freights work
because we love those characters
completely agree and I think that's the
strength of the the narratives now we're
getting like having the woods did a
really great job making us love them so
quick yeah yeah yeah time for twist is
that something you want to make Hill
House is that something you want to make
that corner where you're so invested in
the new ones of the characters that by
the time it gets to be fully terrifying
you're already with them absolutely and
I mean this is sort of like you know we
live in a time of tremendous distraction
there's so much entertainment clutter
out there a lot of it's great you know
but it's hard to get your signal through
the noise there's a thousand streaming
channels there are so many films there
are so many books you're supposed to
read so many great comics how do you get
through the clutter and for me you know
I I place my faith in suspense you know
if you're walking on the street and you
look up and you see a man crawling on a
Ledge ten feet above the street ten ten
stories above the street to rescue a
kitten you don't look away from that you
know and so my job is to is to give you
a character that you can you can get
excited about who you love who you want
to spend time with you want to invite
your life and then I have to get them
out on the ledge and keep them there for
five or six issues the other thing is
the other thing is is these are the Hill
House titles are enclosed tales of
Terror so they have beginnings middles
and ends and I also think that matters I
think it's helpful for readers to know
that there will be closure and and I
also think that endings give the
beginning and middle power the stories
that just go on and on and on you know
ultimately start to lose emotional steam
because there are no stakes you know
because you know it will never end it's
like a prequel you know the character is
gonna make it because you're pretty sure
that character was gonna make it do it
okay yeah now we're also living in an
age where more chances are being taken
with comics because I feel like the
movies are making enough of a noise that
we can try these writings like immortal
Hulk is a full-blown horror comic
against the Hulk oh yeah yeah yeah
that's awesome is there is there any
impact in the way horror is affecting
the movies that's allowing you to make
this comic a little more different
maybe it would have been five years ago
it was let's stay with Hulk for a second
cuz cuz because so like when I was a
comic-book writer before I was a
novelist you know my big breakthrough
was when I got a chance to write an
11-page spider-man story for spider-man
unlimited and you know when I was like
in my teens in my 20s you know I wasn't
reading like John Updike and John
Cheever I was reading screwed-up horror
comics by Alan Moore and Neil Gaiman and
Jamie Delano you know that's what I was
into and and so when I broke through
with spider-man I got I got really
stoked and I'm like you know I this came
at a time when I had written four novels
I couldn't sell and I was just so I'm
like I got to do more of this and I
pitched Marvel on baby Hulk because at
the time I had a toddler and it was like
I had no I'd like because I had watched
TV and I thought toddlers were cute so
full of rage you know like my
two-year-old would pick up like a
plastic truck and go ah ah ah and throw
it across the room and I thought what if
that was a real truck and I'm still I'm
still confused bewildered and a little
hurt that Marvel didn't let me right
baby hold cuz I think that could have
killed I'm so in debate like combining
my love of baby Muppets and is just
everything maybe no awesome yeah alright
internet you've been called to arms
let's make baby Hulk happen yeah yeah
spider-man is there a gateway comic
you'd recommend someone read if they're
not privy to this whole crazy site guys
okay I have a few I have a few gateway
comics I think if you if you if you are
interested in superheroes and you
haven't really read a lot of superhero
comics maybe you've just watched the
movies I would pick up Joss Whedon's
astonishing x-men with the John Cassaday
art because I just feel like that's a
comic that invites everyone in it's so
funny it's so heartbreaking it's
everything we love about Joss Whedon and
to like a dozen issues so I I think that
that's a good one I also think also
staying with superheroes I also think
Batman year one Frank Miller David
Mazzucchelli is the ultimate superhero
story in its purest form I just love
those comics you know moving away to
like if you have like a you know
thirteen-year-old 14 year old you know
who's read Harry Potter
and you know is looking around for
what's next I think Neil Gaiman books a
magic are great placing start there and
then slide into Sandman universe that
trajectory so you know I mean I mean
there's certainly a lot out there for
different tastes and I mean I guess
those would be the three I'd I'd pick if
you know yeah and now having written
both literature and comic books you find
I obviously different mediums have
different strengths what's one of the
strings do you appreciate about the
comic medium I would wouldn't describe
in my own novels I would use the word
literature very loosely you know only in
the broadest most general sense I mean
for me I'm most comfortable writing
comic books I'm that's my comfort zone
other people's discomfort zone is my
comfort zone I feel that comic books
amplify a lot of my strengths and also
sort of hide sweep my weaknesses under
the you know under the rug what I like
to write best is action and dialogue and
that sort of sums comics up you know in
total that's what you get when you get a
comic book is action and dialogue
there's almost no room for anything else
the stuff that I find hardest to write I
find structure challenging you know like
when I write write a novel I'm thinking
like in a novels how do you what's the
structure of a novel you have to invent
the structure every time out whereas
when you're writing a comic book a
22-page comic book is as formal as a
Shakespearean sonnet it has a set of
secret rules and once you've
internalized those rules you can do
almost anything and so I love I love the
that that instead of trying to figure
out structure for myself it's been
implanted from without you know forced
on me from without I find that you know
I grow I climb that structure like a
flower climbing a trellis yeah
literature what you just said I totally
see that oh thank you just gonna get
full credit
now with comic books being the the
cultural landmark they are now they
weren't always yeah how did you first
discover comics and what made you fall
in love with that medium as I see the
strengths in it but why did you call to
that instead of books or anything else
well so when I was a kid my boys just
broke like I still AM I'm regressive
when I was a kid my the very first book
that I really got into was my dad picked
a big thick paperback graphic novel
called bring on the bad guys
you know the book you know the boy oh
yeah the only credit on the cover was by
Stan Lee excelsior you know I mean you
know what what was them I think it was
Captain Marvel that began with the
credit that was just like a whole
montage of Stan Lee's you know Jamie
cameos and I'm like by the time the
Marvel logo logo had faded from the
screen I'm like wiping you know but yeah
so when I was like six
you know the book that I was obsessed
with was bring on the bad guys which was
a story of a collection of origin
stories about Marvel's greatest
Psychopaths
you know the abominations Dormammu Red
Skull you know and I must have had my
dad to read that book to me a hundred
times
you know dozen times anyway him doing
all the voices so there was really never
any turning back from that yeah and I
think he's always like you know been in
the comic space with that charity Bucky
did the x-men and I love the Green
Goblin
wow that was your deep now here's the
comic right there he did a single page
in the charity x-men thing Tim I can
almost remember it was like this corpse
was like didn't had this rhyme like pass
the gravy let's eat something like that
good but and it's on the cuff like it's
a and it's magneto in the purple suit
and it's a yeah actually that's a really
good book yeah well you know he also
when I was yes did a film called creep
show with George a Romero that was like
a tribute to the great gory 1950s horror
comic books which is where we started
this conversation yeah you know and so
it was basically those horror comic
books on screen as a weird point of
trivia I was in that film I was the
little kid with the voodoo doll who you
know who kills his on-screen father for
taking away his comic books so it's all
life reflecting art and we come right
back
I was kinda doomed from the start you
know I mean like so actually weirdly Tom
Savini did the gross out special effects
on Creepshow flash-forward 40 years I
wrote a short story called by the Silva
waters of Lake Champlain and it's about
two kids who discover the washed up
corpse of a lake monster on on Lake
Champlain that's going to be it's been
filmed as an episode for shudders
Creepshow anthology series which is
coming out later this year and Tom
Savini directed it oh that's amazing
that Wow how many of life reflecting
arts is that that's so many stacks of
meta I think I won't get in trouble for
saying that people Savini also has a
cameo in the lock and key series that
Netflix is doing that will be out next
year amazing I think I can get away I
mean it's been I've been excited for
that show I wasn't gonna necessarily as
medic as I know it's Netflix and they're
very intent on their secrecy right there
are things like you know I can say this
I've seen the first eight episodes and
it's like TV crock oh so addictive yes
but I can't say stuff like if I were to
talk about like for an example and a
release a release date a black
helicopter would land behind us with
like the N logo on the sides and on the
side the black bag over my head and they
drive me off to like Netflix one time
I'm going to take away like oh no they
said another bag over the camera it's
gone you never happened that's the
beautiful thing about these properties
they're taken so seriously yeah we're
making a lock-and-key show that isn't
going to be something that would get
tossed aside locking Keys getting the
investment it deserves and I think
that's a beautiful thing and the culture
we're living in now a comic book well
and I mean you look at you look at you
know there has been a lot of film and a
lot of TV made out in your game it's
work you know some of it really good
some of it maybe not you know good
effort you know but then you see what
Amazon did with Good Omens and you hear
about Netflix taking a swing it at
Sandman and if you're if you're a geek
for this stuff if you love dark fantasy
if you love hor if you love those comics
there's never been a better time to be
alive estimated because you know it's
gonna be awesome because you know the
source was right there and you know you
trust the Empire's that are building
absolutely to completely invest in it to
the hilt and to take the material and
got it and really think about what did
the readers of this material love and
how can we honor that how can we make it
thrilling on TV and still honor those
things instead of running from it
because when things have failed I mean
like I actually thought the Keanu Reeves
Constantine film was pretty good I I
think it's a pretty fun film but I can I
can also see how if you loved the
character if you loved the comics it
didn't quite hit it you know wasn't
really exactly what you know even down
to I know Keanu Reeves is the internet
boyfriend now and so I love it I love
Keano and I would never speak ill of him
but but think if it had been more
closely aligned with what was in the
comics and it had been Sean Bean oh you
know is Constantine I mean that could
have been amazing I've always seen it as
he's a John Constantine he's not
Hellblazer and right exactly yeah well
and I mean actually you know out of
loyalty to Alan Moore I never saw the
Watchmen film I'm pretty psyched though
for the Damon Lindelof HBO series
rattling it's gonna be great and I think
DC strength right now is they're taking
these big risks and I love that what
they're doing the black label is they're
both you know your own corner but also
the film Black Label effectively Joker
is a black label fill right into that
it's its own universe Scott it looks so
good incredible but the car I've watched
the trailer over and over and over again
and and I think I think there's a I mean
I'm gonna go out on a limb right now and
say what Kim Phoenix definitely Academy
Award nomination and I'm basing that on
the trailer and I know that's going way
out on a limb except that I have you
know except that you've seen his other
work right and though this material is
perfect and and he might be the second
person to win an Oscar for playing the
Joker and how weird is that I just the
two things that break the mold being the
Joker with Heath and then the festival
run because if you look at it they're
already saying festival instead of being
here at San Diego with us so if the
Joker is the character that breaks that
first acting Oscar and breaks the
festival mold and get the credibility of
comics I'm just saying the job wonderful
Hamlet the Joker's Hamlet I'm saying
it's it's like the greatest trailer ever
made yeah you know for a superhero film
and I if the film can deliver half of
what we saw it'll be like one of my
favorite
a year so how is Black Label in the
comics ID since you're working directly
with that that's your imprint are they
or is there the freedom that would looks
like we're getting Todd Phillips has as
there is the okay so here's the deal
with the hill house comics which is
coming out under the black label you
know the first the the first title we're
coming out with is basket full of heads
which you can tell from the title is
gonna be a tasteful restrain nuanced
look at [ __ ] it's gonna be elevated
[ __ ] yeah it's really it's almost like
nothing's going to even happen it's
almost gonna be sort of like
impressionistic no PG yeah yeah yeah
Vanguard kind of thing you know
no so basket full of heads is the story
it's set in September of 1983 it's about
a young woman named June Branch who
comes into possession of an ancient
Viking axe that can take off a man's
head in a single swipe but after the
head comes off it's still it's still
talking and thinking so life continues
when when the head is decapitated with
this incredible axe and it turns out
this is the weapon she very much needs
because she finds herself confronted
with four home invaders who have a
lethal and frightening agenda of their
own and so so like I I'm not into campy
horror
I'm not into horror that is
intentionally bad for the sake of being
bad like sharknado nothing wrong with
that thing it's just not what I do it's
not my thing sure I like the authentic
article I like you know stories where we
care about the characters and then
they're put in terrifying grisly
situations full of moral complications
and you know psychological horror and
you know and plenty of the red stuff
splashing around
I want tension and suspense and you know
and hopefully we'll get that with basket
full of heads yeah and then and and then
with the other titles as well they talk
too much I'm worried I talk too much
about Netflix just swooping in a little
closer so right right so there's
basketful heads we've got the dollhouse
family by Mr Carey who did the amazing
girl with all the gifts as well as
unwritten and Lucifer so he's a pro he's
a stone-cold pro I don't need to tell
him about how to write comments
tell me the dollhouse family is great
because it's like it takes one of these
concepts that's like a heartwarming why
a novel concept you know this little
girl with a dollhouse
that's magic and inside the little
figures all come to life which just
sounds wonderful it's horribly you know
screwed up terrifying and it's a real
throwback to the kind of horror the
vertigo was doing before vertigo even
really existed like the very early days
of Swamp Thing and Sandman and you know
and I love it it's great we're doing a
comic with Cara Maria Machado who was a
brilliant young writer and her her
collection her body and other parties is
like you know one of the best books of
the last decade and she's doing a thing
which is kind of like David Cronenberg
meets David Lynch it's yeah it's it's
the lolo woods it's set in a town called
shudder to think pennsylvania and
ostensibly the story is about two young
women who are investigating an outbreak
of forgetfulness in this little town but
it's so much weirder than that
it's got in the woods there are these
packs of people walking around known as
the skinless men who are very very
dangerous and then there's a crack a
smoking crack in the earth that goes to
something that's that's much more
terrible than a cavern to then some so
much more terrible than a mineshaft and
so I'm really excited for that one it's
so you know it's so weird and so trippy
and so fun we're working with a woman
named Laura Marx who comes out of TV she
wrote for brain-dead she wrote for The
Exorcist she worked on the Hulu
incarnation of lock-and-key and she
really gets horror and she's very witty
she's doing a story called Daphne Byrne
and Daphne Byrne is you know it's a kind
of ghost by Gaslight story it's also a
little bit like The Omen and petticoats
you know it's set in New York in the
19th century and it's real fun and
quirky and scary horror legend Kelly
Jones is doing the art for it I've
already seen a couple pages that are
absolutely transcendent and so I'm
excited for that I'm doing another comic
called plunge
it's not it's not set in the world of HP
lovecraft
but it was sort of inspired by a
Lovecraftian riff you know I was
thinking about fossil fuel I was
thinking about like so when we pump oil
low to the ground you're pumping out a
prehistoric forest that's been pressure
and time has reduced it to a fossil fuel
that we can burn for power I was
thinking like so
Lovecraft postulated the existence of
this island rila that's sunken deep
underwater and is the home of all the
sleeping great elder gods like Cthulhu
and I was thinking so they've been down
there for a long time so they've melted
down to fossil fuel now you'll be like
to pump oil that's actually the blood of
the great oil and so that became the
Nugget of a story that became a thing
that's kind of like a riff on
Carpenter's The Thing okay so it's sort
of like Arctic horror people strand yeah
yeah the Arctic Circle and like for that
and then there's also gonna be a backup
feature that runs in every title and
that one is called Sea Dogs I'm writing
that one as well and it basically it
asked the question how did the scrappy
Revolutionary Army beat the Brits
because at that at in in the you know
nineteen eighteenth century the British
Royal Navy was the greatest fighting
force the world had ever known how could
we beat them and my answer is werewolves
naturally you know I mean it's right
there today they had they had hundred
gun you know ships of the line but we
had werewolves advantage and comics
allow for the ultimate budget so I can't
wait to dancing at world of werewolves
being on ships and it's gonna be great
it's fantastic so cool there's no budget
restraints there's no time constraint I
love that Beauty million like you put
you put a three-masted ship-of-the-line
you know a triple decker ship with a
hundred cannon on it man you already
blown your budget yeah yeah you didn't
even get to the werewolves and here we
are at a time where this medium is
everything and it's the perfect time for
this whole orc I love the [ __ ] readings
six at the beginning so we get this
beautiful universe I think I think it's
gonna be what horror comics need right
now I'm really excited for well thanks
so much I'm psyched for - I cannot wait
to see what happened and I'm really
looking forward to seeing the resurgence
of the horror air that started all this
because that's really these worlds are
coming together for the first time it's
a it's a it's a good time
it's a good time to be writing scary
stuff and and there's so much great
stuff out there it's nice to just be a
little part of it awesome well thank you
so much man I appreciate it it was a
blast
thanks talking you